everywhere we turn omicron and the
coveted pandemic dominate the
conversation just today the u.s food and
drug administration authorized pfizer's
covid19 vaccine for booster shots in 12
to 15 year old kids this is happening
against the backdrop of young people
returning to classrooms after the
holiday break so to help us make sense
of this latest iteration of the fight
against kovid dr angela rasmussen
virologist at the university of
saskatchewan joins us now
dr rasmussen thank you so much for
joining us if you could start us off by
giving us your quick take on what
today's news from the fda means
do you see it playing a meaningful role
in slowing the spread
i do um and part of the reason for that
is that we've known since really omicron
emerged
that two doses of the vaccines or being
fully vaccinated
does still provide significant
protection against severe disease
however the effect effectiveness of the
vaccine has gone down considerably in
terms of preventing infection altogether
adding a booster shot really raises the
levels of neutralizing antibodies which
are essentially your first line of
defense against being infected so that
should improve the vaccine effectiveness
uh at preventing infection as well as
protecting against severe disease during
a time when people are going back to
school when kids are going back to
school
and they will be in situations where
they may be exposed to omicron it's
important that they go back into those
situations as protected as possible from
infection as well as from disease right
and you've now just enabled a larger
portion of the population to be boosted
as well the fda also pushed back the
booster timeline from six months to five
months cutting it by one month so
millions of people are now five or six
months out from their booster jab as a
result as well those who got their
boosters early on not that the cdc is
adopting this perspective of the sooner
the better for these third shots where
does that leave us
with regards to a fourth shot for people
who are now say five to six months out
from their original booster shot
as far as i know this isn't something
that's been actively considered here in
the u.s although in israel uh healthcare
workers and some subsets of vulnerable
people have been offered a fourth shot i
imagine that if that does seem to be
very effective in further decreasing
transmission that is something that
would be on the table here um but for
right now i think that it's really
important to concentrate on making sure
that people get their third booster um
since there's still a lot of people who
have not received a booster shot yet as
well as vaccinating those who remain
unvaccinated
got it got it taking a step back here
when we look at what's happened in south
africa we've seen omicron peak there it
ripped through the country and then now
it's on the decline do you expect to see
the same patter playing out in europe
and then the us
so far it is looking uh based on data
from europe that that is probably the
trajectory of this omicron does spread
incredibly fast uh that means that in
any given community that that should
peak relatively quickly but i'd caution
people into saying that that's directly
translatable we're not going to go
through one peak as an entire country
all at the same time
new york is a couple weeks ahead of
other cities uh within the us and
certainly it will take some time for
omicron to be distributed throughout the
country so i think we'll be seeing a lot
of different uh quick peaks of omicron
across the country in different
communities depending on when omicron
begins spreading there gotcha okay well
so far we've also all observed how
omicron is more transmissible than
previous variants including delta but so
far it's also more mild it's less
virulent so there is an argument that
perhaps we don't need to be
i guess as cautious about this variant
maybe let it spread so we can get it
over with that the argument being that
let it chew through the population let
people build up some natural immunity
you are an expert virologist does the
science back this idea up
the science absolutely does not back
that idea up for starters omicron may
not actually be less virulent and
unvaccinated people or people who've had
no prior exposure to stars coronavirus
ii some data came out of ontario today
where there's also a huge omicron surge
occurring and that showed that there
really wasn't a difference in the number
of cases between vaccinated versus
unvaccinated people but overwhelmingly
the people who are being hospitalized
the people who are in the icu are
unvaccinated people so i don't think we
should make the assumption that omicron
is actually milder
it's just that people who have been
vaccinated or who have had a prior
infection are going to be more capable
of controlling the disease
now that said uh i think that that it is
really important
to to focus on what the numbers mean too
so any time that we have a variant
whether it's milder or not that is
causing a lot of cases that means that
there's going to be a lot of
hospitalizations and we're already
seeing signs that healthcare systems in
many places that have been going through
large omicron surges are being very
strained so even if it's an overall
lower percentage of people who are
becoming severely ill and requiring
hospital care
if there's a lot of cases that still
translates to an absolutely large number
of people so we really should not just
let it rip through the population and
consider this a free booster shot i
think we need to to do everything in our
power to stop transmission of omicron
just like we would for any other variant
okay i i hear what you're saying here
however anecdotally all signs are so far
that omicron is uh more mild than delta
having seen that omicron is more
transmissible but apparently more mild
less virulent what does that tell us
about what the next variant might look
like do variants evolve in a linear
fashion
no so evolution doesn't occur in a
linear fashion and it's a very
frequently repeated myth that viruses
naturally become attenuated the longer
that they circulate in a given host
population
so again omicron is not necessarily
milder it's milder in people who've been
vaccinated and have
immune systems that can mount a rapid
and competent response against it that's
different than being milder actually and
the reason why this is important is that
delta did cause increased breakthrough
infections but the pattern of severe
disease is essentially the same for
omicron and delta omicron's infecting
more vaccinated people but the people
overwhelmingly who are ending up in the
hospital because of it just like the
delta are people who've not yet been
vaccinated so i think regardless of of
what new variants might come out now
they do seem to be under selection
for variants that are more transmissible
which is no surprise because a virus is
basically only function in the world is
to make more copies of itself and be
transmitted from host to host
i think that we can expect future
variants to potentially be more
transmissible their virulence is is a
matter of question but one thing we do
know is that the immune system is
mounting responses that are very
cross-protective in terms of preventing
disease so the vaccines that were
developed against the original recipe
stars coronavirus 2 are actually still
quite effective at preventing severe
disease caused by delta and by omicron
so i think our focus really needs to be
not worrying so much about what variants
might be like but focusing on getting
everybody immunized as fast as possible
to prevent the impact that those future
variants might have thank you for
explaining that distinction and again
the message from the medical community
remains consistent which is to get
vaccinated to get your booster shots you
i know study vaccines dr rasmussen will
the pandemic only end once we've
developed invented some kind of pan
variant vaccine that will cover all
existing and i mean hopefully future
variants
well i know that the vaccine
manufacturers are developing variant
specific boosters and they've actually
already tested them back in february
moderna tested a beta-specific booster
but as i mentioned the vaccines are
still really holding their own in terms
of their ability to prevent severe
disease and ultimately that's what we
really need vaccines to be doing it's
not so much just preventing infection
that's that's certainly wonderful when a
vaccine does that but the real risk here
is is making sure that we're keeping
people out of the hospital making sure
that we're keeping people out of the
morgue and the vaccines are still
largely doing that so i don't think that
we're going to be waiting for
a pan variant or a universal sars
coronavirus 2 vaccine to end the
pandemic i do think though the end of
the pandemic is going to be dependent on
vaccinating the entire world and in many
places we're severely behind in terms of
our ability to do that there are some
countries where a very very small
percentage of the population has
received even one dose of vaccine so if
we want to focus on ending the pandemic
it's getting vaccines into arms period
not necessarily getting variant specific
vaccines into arms understood
there's also an argument out there that
we don't really have a good read on how
widespread the viruses in the u.s do to
at-home testing even though we're seeing
spikes it's just what's been reported
other people say we should look at
hospitalizations as the best way to
gauge um the state of the virus in the
u.s not case counts i'm curious what
statistic you look at you rely on you
find most helpful in framing your
understanding of where we are at right
now
boy i wish there were just one i think
that we need to look at all of those
things i mean certainly it's going to be
different from one community to the next
and that's going to depend a lot on
demographics uh you know the relative
risk of people who are living in a given
community it's going to depend on how
many of those people have been immunized
it's going to depend on how many uh
coveted surges have gone through the
population before how much population
immunity there is
certainly when we're when we're thinking
about how this is impacting all of us we
have to look at the health care system
and see how much strain it is under and
certainly in places like new york city
the health care system is being very
very strained we don't necessarily have
to have the most accurate count of cases
to understand this especially since in
highly vaccinated or highly immunized
places we're starting to see the
hospitalizations decouple from from the
number of cases overall but i think it
is really important to to maintain a
look at what's going on in our hospitals
where we're at for capacity and how fast
cases are spreading too because
certainly part of hospital capacity is
the ability to staff those hospitals and
if everybody's getting coveted at the
same time whether they have severe
illness or not that's a huge problem in
terms of the health care system's
ability to manage the incoming coveted
cases that are serious yeah so i think
that that really the answer is d all of
the above
with demand spiking um and also supply
limited that's that's what you're going
to get
i'm curious also to hear about your
thoughts on where we are at when it
comes to testing because some people say
with omicron the rapid tests don't work
as well others will say that the pcr
tests don't necessarily pick it up can
you help us understand how reliable
current tests are
yeah so this is something that is
definitely an emerging area of research
there has been some preliminary data
reported that the rapid antigen tests
are less sensitive for omicron but they
do still detect it and that's actually
expected because most of the rapid
antigen tests detect the nuclear capsid
protein of the virus which is produced
in really high quantities and
importantly an omicron does not have
nearly as many mutations as the spike
protein
now the molecular tests the pcr tests
are a little different because each one
of them is different um and some of them
do not work to detect omicron because
they're they're based on the genetic
sequence of the virus if they look at a
part of the virus that's particularly
mutated and omicron those rapid or those
pcr tests are not going to pick those up
so it really is an area where we
definitely need more information the fda
is providing information on which
molecular tests are not effective and so
places should continually
people that are providing clinical care
and those tested people should
continually check with the fda to make
sure they're using tests that will
detect omicron um but i think that you
know really with testing the moral of
the story is that we're not anywhere
near where we need to be we need to have
access to testing nationwide we need to
have both rapid tests and pcr tests
accessible to people and right now uh
rapid tests are very very difficult to
find in many parts of the country um the
turnaround time for pcr tests can exceed
sometimes five days which is completely
unacceptable uh in terms of being able
to make a decision that that is really
dependent on the results of that test
whether you should isolate or not
whether you need to be prescribed
medication um all of those things are
really dependent on having access to
fast reliable testing and we have a long
way to go in that department i wonder if
that uneven reliability of tests has to
do with
what the cdc decided to
shift its isolation guidance for
asymptomatic positive
people from 10 days to five days
dr fauci suggested that these people who
are asymptomatic but tested positive
may
have to get a test at some point that
followed a lot of backlash over the cdc
guidance what's your take on the
five-day isolation guidance from the cdc
what do you think is the strategy behind
it
so i i think what you just said is
exactly the strategy behind it that's
why a testing component wasn't included
um i think that the the rationale here
was the concern that so many people
would be required to isolate for a
10-day period of time that we would stop
having access to essential services and
not just healthcare services but also
things like public transportation
grocery stores things like that we've
already seen a number of flight
cancellations for example right at the
peak season of holiday travel because
people are testing positive on the on
the crews of different flights and
they're not able to actually staff those
things so i think the motivation behind
that guidance was to make sure that that
people could actually go to work now the
problem is and i understand i guess i'll
back up i understand why the cdc did not
include a testing component although i
don't agree with that um and the reason
they didn't include a testing component
is of course because tests are very
difficult to get a pcr test the
turnaround time is long and rapid
antigen tests are
sold out in many places so it would be
very difficult to practically implement
a testing component to this but that
said i think that that it still should
include a testing component because
while the majority of transmission does
occur uh prior to symptom onset and
immediately after symptom onset that's
probably going to resolve by five days
after infection i know a number of
people anecdotally who have reported
that they're still testing strongly
positive on rapid antigen tests well
after five days into their isolation
period now the rapid antigen tests are
not a pure correlate of whether or not
you're contagious or potentially trans
uh able to transmit the virus
but i would say that those rapid tests
are less sensitive if you're getting a
strong positive more than five days
after that does suggest you still have
actively replicating virus in your nose
um and that test is picking it up so
that to me suggests somebody who should
still isolate regardless of what their
symptoms are like
thank you so much for explaining all of
that dr angela rasmussen really
appreciate your time joining us